great strength body strip oh no he's
rolled it through he's popped it through
oh no and again he's going for the
double megs
three
the third one's a little bit
hi i'm joe carl and this is rate my
skills for sport bible
right
oh the drag backs this is pure street
football he's he's pirouetted
and that is just
natural foot sound to do that on grass
quality pure instinctual that's just
years honed on the pitch just you're
learning how to manipulate your body
that's outstanding skill days
oh skill
skill
oh he's gonna go
ah
the young man
what a move that was
he took it one way took it the other way
picks the ball up in his own half here
left foot dribbles past one
drives into midfield keeps driving it
opens up he obliges
over the goal comes in top class got a
chance at that point that's what i used
to try and do because if i was not
getting the board go and try and pick it
up and dribble past everyone i think
most footballers do that whoever was the
best footballer in the area used to do
that but that was a hell of a finish
from the young man
oh was that an own goal
do you try in there
oh my lord
where'd you find these clips look that
is just he's put that in with pure
violence doesn't need to put it onto the
onto the motorway just get it out of
play but he's trying to really smash it
out there and he yeah
he'll regret that one
great strength body strip oh no he's
rolled it through he's popped it through
oh no and again he's gone for the double
megs
free
oh wow
the little easy he thinks he's got him
here he's jumped in
he's come back
that's just pure foot look rolled it
back through
the third one's the third one's a little
bit i actually got nutmeg quite a lot
because
not being a defender you gamble and i
think when you gamble when you go
and you try and nick it
it's easy to get it nutmeg so
it does happen feel free to in the red
there
interfe touch
scoop up
oh
that is a painful one
this makes put it on the plate and um
that's gonna haunt the young man that is
we've all done that you can't be a
footballer lionel messi's done that so
for the young man listen you're in good
company next time concentrate stop
staying up all night playing computer
games
that was that was decent decent little
celebration as well as soon as he hit
that he would have known that was sweet
the young lad's in it for my third place
the young lad
where he picks up this reminds me of my
youth
you know he's so comfortable like a
young mess he's just driving through and
i love to see the
kids playing football and doing things
like that's what it's all about
triple megs the triple meds on toast
by here where he just rolled it through
there it's the joys of football just
that is just
someone just aims with a ball for that
sir outstanding but here we go this this
is my winner
the body our leader volley
he gets all the time in the world as it
comes out he watches it on his laces i
love the fact he's he he's he's he's
training foot he's just lifted up just
gonna try just to get that sort of
whippage beautiful volley love that
i can see something
funny here okay
is he barefoot why would you do that who
would you suspect most likely to do this
well robert perez when he couldn't pass
the ball to me against man city he did
the same thing the only thing he didn't
fall that would be robert